Marcus is in Los Angeles hey Marcus
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show thank
you so it's a pleasure to talk to you
you too sir how can I help well we just
started the program and we went we were
in baby step two now we're back to baby
step one just gaining the thousand
dollars because we started out with
fifty six thousand dollars in debt and
we had our financial meaning it turns
out there's actually two hundred in five
thousand more dollars added to that
I'm so confused
you were you had two hundred thousand
dollars worth of debt you didn't know
you had yes sir how is this possible
explain to me it's possible because the
honesty and our marriage it wasn't
supposed to be and I mean I'm in a tough
spot right now because I'm not going to
leave my family 1 & 2 when the truth had
to come out when it came I'm gonna do
this in a bad way
ok so you're saying your wife had hid
$200,000 worth of debt from you yes
holy crap I don't think I want to be at
that kitchen table when that comfo my
friends I say yeah well I started this
financial piece but I guess before peace
comes war how long you been married
what's your household income our
household income mine is about a honey
well actually to be exact it's a hundred
and fifty two thousand dollars okay and
does she work outside the home mm-hmm
what the Shema is that part of that
money okay one hundred and forty two
things so how are you married for 17
years and she possibly has a life the
size of two hundred thousand dollars off
to the side that you don't know about
that the same question I had
I'm asking you because your that says
says you're not plugged into your wife
very well you're right kind of a thing
um there was a living fool to get her
PhD and I how much of this is student
loan debt 205 well absolutely
205 plus 25 more thousands in London
okay so it's all student loan debt but
mostly yeah okay so you knew she was
going to school and you knew you weren't
paying for it how did you think it was
being paid for here go to the back part
this is the back of price you see after
it came out that I was swimmer $2,000 I
asked well where does it come from how
did it happen um she said well I'll
really look back and really they're
gonna be about fifty thousand dollars
then I should have used to get my
education and after I said is there a
bank account with a hundred fifty
thousand dollars
I don't know about that I know about
their iris and of course the answer is
no so I don't know we don't have a
lifestyle so we're you have to have a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars extra
and I don't know I don't know all right
there's several things going on here
okay there's the future which the two of
you attack at two hundred and some
thousand dollar debt pile with a hundred
and forty two thousand dollar income
that's thing what
there's the past where the two of you
have to get a real clear understanding
on what actually occurred in the past in
order to start to rebuild not only your
financials but also your trust you know
in our world we call this financial
infidelity because this this level of
breach of trust
this level of you being asleep at the
wheel and hurt a lion or butt off while
you're asleep at the wheel it
approximates having an affair in this in
the emotional space and so you guys are
going to have to get out and sit down
with a marriage counselor and unpack
this as to how you're this asleep at the
wheel and how she's willing to lie at
this level and and throw up her hands
and go I have no idea where 150 grand
went so you've got to rebuild that trust
to be able to go forward in your
relationship and the only possible way
that you repay this together is to go
forward in your relationship I assume
your name is not on the loans unless she
committed criminal fraud so it may be
she has the loans if there were a
divorce and I'm not recommending a
divorce but I'm saying that you guys
have got to walk through the rebuilding
of your relationship very similar to a
couple that has experienced an
adulterous affair it's not the same but
it's pretty close
old with a lot of people and the way
you're talking this through that's the
way it sounds so and this is very
extreme because of the numbers so I'm
gonna highly recommend a good marriage
counselor as step one for your finances
to be healed